here's sean payton coach of the saints
on dan patrick's show from tuesday now
that they
have drew brees retired taysom hill
restructured jameis winston re-signed
sean payton talking about whether to
what extent the saints are
finished at adding quarterbacks to the
depth chart
are you set at the quarterbacking
position
i think we are i think we are and and
look there there will be a few calls we
made but our goal coming into the
offseason was to
obviously re-sign jameis
payson played for us in four games last
year
and let those guys go to work and and
and i'm excited about it i'm excited
about those two now there there are a
few things
that it may still be out there but i i i
see those two
competing for this position who's your
starting quarter
give me your depth chart right now who
who is the uh who's
the first two are going to be sitting
there i mean obviously i've
told both of them hey it's going to be
you know the two of you are going to
compete for this position
in in uh and they understand it
and they'll come in we've already had a
chance to to see both of them to some
degree i think
last year was important for us relative
to
jamis we had had taser in the building
but
it gave us a year to evaluate him and it
also gave him a year to evaluate us
and and i think that was important
and hey it worked out for the saints the
praise of jameis winston was real
it didn't cause someone else to swoop in
and grab jameis winston and now he has
an opportunity
to to win the job and that's consistent
with what peyton told us
he said it elsewhere it's a competition
it's always a competition there's no
sacred cow there
it's taysom hiller it's jameis winston
and winston's going to have a chance to
win the job and you know what we're
probably going to see both guys
especially if winston does win the job
will pricey taysom hill doing exactly
what he's been doing for the past
several years chris
that's right i mean i i agree with you
there like if james winston did win the
job i mean
yeah you're still going to see i think
taysom hill run packages and of course
he'll be on the field being a hvac a
fullback a slot receiver
all those type of things there's no
doubt um
you know i i would imagine mike just at
base level
like when they start training camp and
yeah they're going to compete that
that it will be taysom hill's job to
lose it will be a competition but i
would say he gets the first team reps
that first day
week of training camp right probably
into that first preseason game
and you see where it goes from there but
hey the evaluation like shawn talked
about
and one he got to see taysom hill play
quarterback which was big
you know because the year before it was
teddy bridgewater and he did some really
good things
and then of course yes like he talked
about also the jameis winston evaluation
and just seeing you know the man what
he's capable of how did he adapt to the
offense and
you know absorb it all obviously from
everything we've
heard from him when he's talked to us he
kind of gushes about jameis
so he's obviously excited i will say
this
i think we're set at quarterback there
might
still be something out there though
though
i mean sean payton as we know the reason
i love sean payton
is because he's honest i mean you know
he's he wears wears it on his sleeve he
really does
he he always has i mean even like hey
last year he tweets at pro football talk
right like
insiders on the outside just where they
should be he's cool like that
and to me that like just little inkling
there meant
maybe there's something still on their
radar but like 95
sure it's gonna be jameis winston and
taysom hill
and you can't seal off opportunities
because you never know what's going to
fall
no i know you're right no you never know
right um but uh
and you're always looking for upgrades
you're always looking for better and hey
they can make it work with taysom hill
and jameis winston
definitely they're not they're not top
10 quarterbacks in the nfl and if some
guy falls into your lap some way somehow
you don't want to seal off that
possibility i think the draft is a
possibility
as well potentially for new orleans
saints so
uh hey what one thing we know about the
saints
with sean payton crafting the offense
constantly looking for new ideas new
plays new ways to get the most out of
the 11 guys he has
on the field at any given moment they
are going to be competitive
and they probably are going to be pretty
damn good even without drew brees all
due respect to drew brees
i'm not concerned that the saints are
going to fall off the face of the earth
now that drew brees has retired because
sean payton had a hell of a lot to do
with why drew brees did what he did i
want to take anything away from drew
brees right but sean payton had a hell
of a lot to do
with what we've seen over the last 15
years from drew brees
no doubt a lot to do over the 15 years
and really more specifically i think to
what you're saying mike is just
the last few years especially has been
at least more sean payton in my eyes
than drew brees
it's been you know the re-orchestrating
of the offensive line the run game of
course the taysom hill package
kind of tailoring the offense a little
bit to drew
and the fact that hey yeah the arm was
diminishing and those type of things so
that's very special we've seen them be
successful without drew brees i mean
what are they
eight and one the last two years without
them i believe it's right around that
range it's 7-1 8-1 i think taysom hill
went 3-1 last year right teddy
bridgewater 5-0 the year before
they're still you know a really good
football team
but man they've had to make a lot of
moves they've had to shake up that
roster a little bit to where it's
affected their
depth and things like that but none of
the real marquee players which i think
you can look at and still go
you know the saints are still going to
be a force in the nfc and i don't expect
them to go anywhere to
what you're saying eight and one
combined between
2019 and 2020 during the games that drew
brees missed
eight and one that's a higher winning
percentage
i suspect than drew brees generated
during his time with the new orleans
saints eight and one is pretty damn good
right again not that not that that's
sustainable it's a short period of time
and by the time that the defenses have
fully figured out what sean payton's up
to drew brees is back
but we'll find out this year whether
it's jameis winston taysom hill
or who knows mystery candidate the
saints
should be fine even though they will be
dealing with the tampa bay buccaneers
twice as they always do and the damn bay
buccaneers the defending
nfl champions
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports